you don't seem very shy I asked you to
come here and you were like okay I'll
come to the front you know that was you
we're right there you just came to the
front you know there was no hesitation
right you just came no problem
I'm I'm a big fan of nonverbal
communication so I don't need to use
words to talk sometimes I've been able
to find people that are very under the
radar nobody really knows about them in
the big media and I like finding them
and showcasing them like here's you know
here's me like if you give if you give
the really good answer to the question
and I know that you would be a good
person to keep in touch with this is
what I do right away
hey that was so cool can we keep in
touch on on WeChat can I message you you
know right away I just go right away and
they said yeah sure and then I'm like
then we scan and then we become friends
I message you my name my email right
away my phone number so you have it you
know so we're in touch don't wait well
don't wait why are you waiting if
someone's really interesting get their
contact information and follow up with
them the next day that was great to meet
you you know here's that paper I was
talking about what do you think about it
do you want to meet up on Thursday for
coffee and talk about it more I'll come
with more research because when you
don't take this out and do it right away
you forget about them they forget about
you the opportunity goes away so seize
the moment carpe diem seize the day
could get connected right away to the
person that you find interest and follow
up with them know someone's opinion may
contradict yours what is my friend Alan
it's all about your perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality so this is the opening of
our question portion so if you could
maybe start with your name and then also
what you study here at the picking Life
Sciences okay okay and then ask the
question hello I have a question I am
tell Lou i'm studying neuroscience and
undergraduate student in packing
university i have a question that what
he is your background in in your
undergraduate study and PhD good
question and i I was wondering that how
can how do you how do you carry in tutor
field of your interviewee as fast as you
can and how do you come up with a
valuable question that take a balance
between the profession and and interest
of the audience who may not know so much
about the field no questions yes that's
a lot of questions okay okay
let's see if we can remember them okay
so the first question is about my
background and how I got into this so I
was born in a place called South Dakota
in the middle of the United States and
then I moved to California when I was 19
years old I went to the University of
Minnesota for two years and then I just
went out to California because I wanted
to execute ideas because I had just so
many ideas and so Silicon Valley is this
place of executors and ideas and so I
wanted to go and I thought I was just
going on a leave of absence for a couple
for a couple months but I ended up
staying out there so I didn't even end
up finishing my undergrad I've been
there seven years now I'm 26 and I've
just been networking with some of the
leaders in Silicon Valley across all
these different fields and I've been
doing things like since I was 23 I
started taking a microphone and camera
and just going on the streets of Silicon
Valley and asking different people what
makes you happy what impact you want to
make in the universe what's something
you did that last scared
these types of questions and then I
started seeing okay well we can start
producing shows around these things so I
started producing shows featuring
different scientists us featuring them
with comedians I was featuring big fit
big future festivals with a thousand
people in the audience different types
of things like that and then it just
came up that we wanted to do this
everyday so we started doing the show
every single day featuring different
leaders every day on the show because
there's just so many smart people and
there's so many different fields and so
it's nice for us to be able to try and
do as many fields as possible and share
that okay what were the other questions
how can you come up with the questions
that are both valuable and and attracted
the audience okay so let's say you're
you're doing research on let's say
you're doing research on on epigenetics
and let's say that you find that the
person that you're doing research on
also has has shared maybe they've shared
personal stories about how they've about
how they've overcome some sort of
struggles in their life journeys leading
up to the point because it's not all
roses we of course have some sort of
struggles that we go through in life so
when you when you when you read content
or you read their publications or you
watch videos with them there's always
gonna be interesting things that you can
take from it about their personal life
about their scientific inquiry and about
just other things that you find
interesting that then you you add your
own spin to that then make it
interesting for other people to ask so
for example I like peope asking people
questions about what their thoughts are
on the direction of our world so like a
very big question about the overall
direction of our world where I like
asking them questions about what they
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world or I like asking them questions
about if they think that are we alone in
the cosmos I like asking them big
questions
so maybe think about yes getting our
questions both into the smallest aspects
of epigenetics but also these
big-picture questions about how the
environment affects our genes over time
and just these bigger questions over
thousands of years but also about the
nuance of the DNA at the most molecular
level so there's all of the in-between
from the smallest in the world to the
biggest in the world and just thinking
about who's your audience is your
audience going to be people that are
already very deeply interested in
science or is the audience going to be
someone that's maybe somewhat interested
in science and they so so it's there's a
phrase called explain like I'm 5 e Li 5
and that means you want to like you want
to be able to explain something to
someone that's 5 years old in the
science so think about how would you
explain epigenetics to a five-year-old
that's a hard subject to explain to a
five-year-old but so but that makes it
so that you become a really good science
communicator that you can inspire
someone that's 5 someone that may not
maybe they're an adult they're 10 15 20
years old 25 years old they don't know
what that is
you can teach them what it is but then
you can also go in to someone that's a
scientist in the field that you can talk
to them about it to so it's kind of like
having a varying amount of degrees of of
intelligence in the field that you can
go and communicate it at the simplest
level but also at the most complicated
level and knowing who your audience is
does that answer the question okay is
there a more question do you have
another one I don't remember
okay okay sure sure thank you yeah
all right all right thank you for coming
you don't be here as a faculty of pre-k
oh so you have used this unique
experience or unique angle of doing your
job and conventionally people usually
take sort of existing rounds for their
career and I would guess most of people
myself included will at least when we
get study will be worrying about our
everyday life for example how to secure
our pay for grad students probably get
their PhD or get a degree rather than at
least in daily life worrying about you
know the sustainable energy you know
what happened there are aliens in the
world you know probably there will be or
there is but everyday life we were just
worrying about you know how to keep my
student graduate okay so how do you
really sort of get into this unique
weight and how do you really parents
probably also I will get star with you
know have certain inspector your fixed
income and oh oh you probably brought
very rich to stories and then you're
worrying about the you know the big
question in the world so that's my
question
yeah yeah it's very good too so
this is this is a hard subject because
many of us have this maybe this inner
desire like an artist is a very simple
way of putting it because artists have a
strong inner desire to go and do
something that's unique in the world but
they don't necessarily have the ability
to get compensated immediately for this
unique thing that they want to bring
into the world and so the same thing
usually when you're going through
graduate and PhD studies is that you
also are usually not getting paid until
you bit your big your big opportunities
until after you've graduated with your
PhD and after you're doing something
really interesting and people want to
hire you into industry or academia when
you have some sort of a why some sort of
inner purpose and inner knowing of that
this is my goal this is my destiny this
is my dream no matter what no matter how
little I'm compensated for it right away
we'll make ends meet in some times in
the United States and in China too we
were talking about this sometimes people
live in you know a couple people in a in
a in a room you know on bunk beds you
know if you if you have to do that so
that you can do what you love every
single day to be able to achieve your
goals what your ultimate destiny is then
make the sacrifices that are needed if
you need to sacrifice your housing
situation if you need a sacrifice some
of the going out we don't I don't go out
I don't go out I there's a very rare
time when there's a group of people that
are very very prominent that I'll go out
and hang out with but otherwise I spend
my time working and that's the thing
there's sometimes people go out to the
bars or they go to the clubs right this
type of things sometimes they just watch
TV for a whole day or whatever that you
know how bad do you want to be
successful how bad do you want to push
the edge of science how bad do you want
to be compensated for your uniqueness in
the world and so when you want it really
badly you'll figure out how to dominate
a small market that nish so if you are
going into mitochondrial studies or RNA
or wherever you're going into you can do
something super deep in that vertical
that nobody else is doing and you can
become an expert at that and dominate it
and when you do that you get compensated
for it and if if you're gonna do
something like maybe beefs an artist or
someone that has to take a little longer
to get compensated for something or like
your longer-term PhD studies that it can
sometimes be really beneficial to do
something like find someone that's your
friend that has a family that has a
little bit of extra finances or maybe a
company that is willing to talk to you
and ask them to be a supporter of you
ask them for a sponsorship and so that's
another interesting thing if you go and
ask 50 companies if they'd be willing to
sponsor your scientific studies or your
artistic studies you have at least asked
maybe one or two of them will say yes
and then you'll get maybe a couple
thousand you want a month to be able to
pursue your interests and so these what
is a couple thousand you want a month
two of the big companies it's nothing
it's zero that's how much it's to them
but they know that if they say that
they're helping fund some of the
cutting-edge scientists or artists or
journalists then they will feel like
they have a deeper meaning and purpose
that they're working with young people
on building a better world and so these
are the things we can do we can ask our
friends that have that have parents that
may be interested in supporting us we
can ask the companies that may be
interested in supporting us
and those are just some of the couple
thoughts that come to mind about that hi
Ellie my name is June and the coronial
stealing from you lonely slab and now
I'm studying some sensory receptors for
the drug development actually I was
wondering yeah you know you have
interviewed so many people in different
fields is different education the
cultural background so I want to know
how to you understand them you know such
short hi for example research
understands your research awesome see
that's a very good question too so this
is a challenging visit for me because
you guys are so much smarter than I am
in life sciences really and so this is
very challenging for me to try and keep
up with what you guys are gonna be
teaching me about your fields and how
deep you're going and what you're
understanding about the life sciences
and so some of the ways that I learn to
deal with with knowing that the person
that I'm talking to is just so much
smarter than I am in the field that
they're teaching is I try and you know I
used this word earlier but I try and
parse and synthesize and so what that
would mean is I would look at what
you're researching and I would try and
find you know there's this principle
called the Pareto principle if you find
that actually 20 percent of your
research is gonna have 80 percent of the
overall ideas that I want to go and
learn from so I need to parse your
research for those 20 percent and study
those 20 percent mostly and so that's
usually what I do so that I can at least
have enough time so I don't get lost in
the in the in the roots but that I can
you know find the fruits of your of your
greatest studies fastest and then learn
from those and then trying an
add some of my own creative takes to
asking you questions about it yeah
another question so could you tell me
the ultimate oh cool were you two doing
this one more time what's a question for
example oh my ultimate goal yeah for to
interview the top 15 people in the world
or something in the what was the second
major I mean so cool you tuned this the
ultimate goal of the show and of doing
the interviews yeah yes that's the
question okay
okay if you do something like look at
our world with a a center point of of
knowledge where the children that are
born into the world are learning things
like they're learning the language
they're learning history science math
etc and then there's this edge of
knowledge so there's the center of
knowledge and this edge of knowledge so
what I find most interesting is to go
and take the cameras and the microphone
to the edge of knowledge to the people
at the very edge of the knowledge and
try and have them teach what they know
through this megaphone to the rest of
people so that someone around the world
and now people watch the show from
around the world and they message us
from all different countries around the
world that they can say something like
oh my god
that changed my life I now see the world
in a new way
I have transitioned the way that I'm
applying these principles in my career
so this is kind of like one of the
ultimate reasons to do this is why don't
we have more people going to the
scientists the entrepreneurs the artists
politicians the leaders at the edge of
knowledge and doing their best to try
and interview them and share their
wisdom share their knowledge with the
rest of the world and get people
inspired and engaged in building the
future so that's that's really one of
the big things send them now and another
big thing is that and you guys ever see
like the over overview effective you
know when you see the the earth from
from space are you guys familiar with
that photo so when you see the Earth
from space you know you really think
about all it's approximately 100 billion
people is what we hypothesize have have
lived and died before
today to build this civilization we have
and it just gives you a greater degree
of empathy and love for the the entire
progress of the human race to get to
this point and it makes it so that all
of these all of these things about why
would we be in war with each other now
these are these are crazy things to
think about when you take this
perspective of everyone has ever lived
on this planet and we need to be better
stewards of the planet we need to be
better caretakers of the planet have a
more sustainable civilization and so
that's why the sustainable development
goals were on there and that's why you
know having a show that at least asks
questions about how we can all better
work together how we can better
collaborate better harmonize I mean
that's why I'm here
I'm here in China because I really care
about helping the world come together
and collaborate and so if we can show
scientists and entrepreneurs and leaders
that we interview in China on our
Channel people around the world will say
oh cool this show goes to China too this
show works with China this is cool
and so it doesn't become some sort of us
and them thing but it's an we're all
here together thing so these are some of
the ultimate yeah reasons yeah I'm from
graduate students in this university and
I have a question is that when you study
in structural biology structural biology
and and the my question is how to be not
be shy when you interview others and and
be yourself okay could you could you
come up here would you be willing to
come up here
remind me come cook them a little closer
what's your what's your name my name is
cha haw
Chun ha yeah so Jeong woo your questions
about how to not be shy
yeah okay what about why why do you ask
the question I'm I'm very shy when when
talking to others so I I want to get
some experience from others and help me
go out of myself
Chuck Chun - what cha Chun Hong jeong-ho
Chun Hall
you don't seem very shy I asked you to
come here and you were like okay I'll
come to the front you know that was you
where right there you just came to the
front you know so but there was no
hesitation right you just came no
problem when I told it to others I feel
very nervous and where where does it
where do where do you feel nervous
where do you feel it in your head and
your in your heart and your stomach I I
think when I talk to others and my my
mind will be can can to work very well
right now how do you feel right now I
relaxed
that's my mind that usually CC you say
you're relaxed it's interesting because
that place where you feel relaxed from
right now if that same feeling can if
you if we you know if we close our eyes
and we feel this feeling
of being relaxed and what that feels
like and then if we practice that
feeling of feeling relaxed more often
when we're by ourselves when we're
approaching people so here's another
thing out of if you have a structural
biology right was something that you
cared about that you're working on
actually I'd like you to some MD
simulations simulations atom atoms how
do the strapped structures how do the
biology moleculus work as people can see
the atom wise things about about biology
molecular walk your life yes and so if
you want to find people to to learn from
that are doing simulation study what
what is how many times have you went and
maybe asked people in person because
here's here's something that that I
learned when I was very young I went and
I started talking to people and learning
from my mistakes and so if we're willing
to step outside of this comfortability
if we're willing to get maybe a little
bit uncomfortable because you know how
we take a little step into what we feel
is uncomfortable and we try and learn
and then we feel more comfortable and
then we take one more step into what we
feel a little uncomfortable so when you
know when you came up here so fast to
come in and talk to me about about
overcoming shyness to me this is a great
example of you just overcoming and just
coming forward and so that same thing is
if you want to talk to somebody maybe in
the field of of MD simulation maybe to
you know take that little step and
say hey you know you're in this field
and I want to I've been researching your
work and asking them a good question and
then learning from that process and then
going and you know doing it again and
kind of being comfortable with taking
the little steps to do does that does
that make sense but maybe I needed to
prepare the questions or just when I
interview him or her and come up as the
question immediately so these two
process are two approaches yes yes yes
so there's a two so those two approaches
are again it's kind of like we want to
work our way into both those approaches
so the one where you do research and
then you already have some notes and you
already know the question or two you
want to ask someone it gives you a
little bit more time to prepare and then
you're ready with your question and it's
it's not so hard to be shy it's maybe a
little bit easier to come to come
forward but there's less shyness when
you can do more research ahead of time
but when you don't have the opportunity
to maybe do research ahead of time and
you're trying to think on the spot of
maybe like the question just what comes
up and a good principle that I've taken
from experiences like that is think when
something comes up think even bigger has
been something that comes up for me that
I like so when you think of something
about MD simulation think about what is
what could like why are we doing MD
simulation right
why what could be the best applications
of MD simulation what how would this
help our health in our science outcomes
around the world you see they'd like the
big questions
we're like the little questions - what's
the best physics simulator that you know
you know so does that kind of is
like just to think about like the best
big questions and try and like think big
so these questions are all prepared
before the interview those questions
right I just came up with those
questions and that's because I have a
habit that I've developed of thinking
big and abstractly about questions like
that and so maybe that would be
something - that could help is that if
you find yourself if you do have time to
research yes research and get the good
questions and then ask and learn from
that process but if you don't have time
to do research if it's just again like
you oh look I see someone walking on the
street oh wow what was that question I
want to ask them if you don't have the
time then think big think big you know
think as big as possible about their
work in about the field that type of
stuff into you sometimes that idea is on
repeat of something like shyness it's
like on repeat in our head that we're
living in I'm shy I'm shy I'm shy and
it's just further programming us into
thinking that about ourselves but what
if you were to say during that talk I
confidently walked up to the front what
if you were to tell yourself that later
tonight okay go back could you
right yeah yeah absolutely try it and
see see how see how Repat earning our
language and what we say about ourselves
can literally change how we present
ourselves in the world
thank you yeah thank you thank you
and my name's Alex Comey annex and
undergraduate student
and there will be a member of villanies
lab so and someone usually told me a
scientist as just human being there will
be someone generous someone will be
means a man will be like I'm gentle and
somebody tough so so my question is have
you ever made some embarrassment in
zhihui some embarrassment times and in
the inner in the interview of your
pastor and how would you deal with this
especially with someone well we have a
conflict but have have a conflict on
your point are y'all just some some of
the view your hold is quite opposite to
him mm-hmm
so how do you handle is this okay this
is good too if anyone tells you that
they've never failed at something then
they're lying to you everyone's
everyone's failed at something
everyone's had struggles with aiming to
achieve what they're trying to do so
I've had plenty of scenarios in
interviews where I've just falling on my
face and and I one of the important
things to do in those scenarios this you
know humility is a big thing for me
because if sometimes I'll catch myself
talking too much when my job is to be
someone that features the different
leaders so instead of talking so much I
maybe pause and figure out how to ask a
good question next
and so these aren't this another thing
to remember is that they're not like
it's not life and death so we sometimes
we get too consumed with oh what's gonna
happen if I you know don't do well etc
it's kind of like what we thought of in
you know in in high school or like
middle school when we were young we're
always worried about who likes us and if
this is going to you know
if I come tomorrow to school and if
something happens and I'm ashamed or
whatever nobody cares about that like
look you're you know you're 20 years old
25 years old you're not thinking about
middle school high school so these as
important as the moments are to do well
in life they're also not life-or-death
moments so to not like overly get
worried about the moment but also to
know that it's important to do well and
to have a good feedback loop with
yourself so that if you do go and you
you know you walk a little bit towards
that that uncomfortability and you and
you and you practice and you learn
something
make sure to learn it go back home think
about it embody it the next the next day
that you go practice practice with the
new knowledge that you took in so that's
a you know closed-loop feedback for your
own personal growth as a meantime you
the you just have a conflict and the
people you interview will will feel
something will feel bad will feel maybe
angry and at the meantime how would you
deal with it okay
this is good okay so if there's some
sort of like a conflict during the
interview maybe of ideas or something
like that so okay so sometimes on the
show I'll ask people about sometimes
we'll talk about artificial intelligence
on the show and when we talk about AI I
usually have lots of questions about AI
I have questions about narrow AI versus
general AI have questions about the
ethics around AI about geopolitics
around AI all these big questions
sometimes people will just say that I
have no worries about it you know and
you know maybe I disagree that there is
something to worry about it and so I'll
say we'll have you thought of the
scenario of where there's a runaway
super intelligence and we haven't had
too much to say about the way that it
goes off into the world and so maybe
they say no I'm not worried
that that's 50 years out and then I say
okay and then we move on to the next
topic so it's I never I never I never
push to try and make people feel
uncomfortable yeah yes so even if
there's like a conflicting viewpoints
asking a question is really good to see
how they feel about it like why do you
feel like there will never be that issue
it's a good way to think like genetic
engineering why do you think there would
never be an issue with it
they say I'm never worried about it or
something like that so to ask a question
yeah yeah also just like staying
peaceful like equanimous you know even
keel because this is what we talked
about during the talk with emotion
regulation is that if you can stay
peaceful at moments of high stress you
can go farther in life instead of
getting really you know just and playing
that on repeat the next day and the next
day the negativity versus you know
staying more even keel yeah and so
treating conflict like it's also
something that's a like a learning
experience for both of ya yeah yeah
thank you hi Alan um you can call from
Professor Tom photos lab and my major in
the epigenetic regulation my question is
when we for example at an academic
meeting and you're in the car on coffee
time we match someone's that is a top
expert in our area and I really want you
attract his attention I mean on for
example to be his PhD student or be his
post all like that um do we have an
otherwise that how I began the question
I mean if I asked him a big question her
missing maybe think I'm not say not the
researcher Hara just how to say the
other field the other field audience
don't know the basic question if I ask
him a specific question about his
research I don't know which one is
better to begin the call
raise the experts I really wants you get
hush ways this is a really good question
yeah yeah if you can combine both try so
can you ask a question that goes into
the very smallest parts of their
research and it shows them that you've
read that and that you know it but then
you maybe talk about its impact on a big
scale in the world so something like
that because maybe you can combine the
two questions in order to make him
realize as I also study in this area so
I asked a specific question and then I
can how to say deep deep this topic and
talk about is impact or effect or the
future that sounds not just began with a
big question yeah have you interview
peoples not like you interviews people
you want to you want to other people
understand this area for me may be
better to ask a specific question about
the small piece of his his research and
then I talk about is effect and makes a
question become bigger and bigger just
like that come on
yeah both and this is a big part of this
is just trial and error learning for you
figuring out how to best represent
yourself in the best way possible for
other people to see you as someone
interesting to collaborate with so we go
through a trial and error process of
figuring it out and at some point it may
be that going into the tiniest bits and
then asking that first and then going to
the bigger stuff in a couple more
questions is best maybe you can combine
both into the first question and that
way they're potentially more they see
that you think big and that you
understand they're they're the smallest
level of their research too so I like
the idea of just challenging yourself to
find a way to maybe integrate both into
the
the big picture but you know but if you
can't then then yeah then show them that
you've went deep into their field with
the first part like you said and then go
your way up to the bigger stuff - yeah
thank you
yeah and do you have your list you have
your five you raised your hand right
about your top okay so that's the big
take you know you already have your list
so what's next is doing your research on
them finding ways to get in touch with
them finding ways to spread maybe meet
with other people in your community
about that research that kind of stuff
you know so that's the next stuff good I
like it
good good thank you thank you sure
thanks my name is Yahya I'm a grad
undergraduate student from school of
life science and I'm studying
neuroscience and my question that in
your opinion what is the point of oral
expression because I think of
interviewer you may have many strategies
for expression coherently and also
calmly because I've noticed that you
have many pauses you're talking so maybe
you it's one of your strategies to help
you express your ideas more coherently
good catch yes that is one of them yes
so the question is what are the
different strategies about oral
expression at its best yeah okay okay
thank you great question
what I'm doing right now is I'm taking
time to formulate the best possible
answer for you and I don't have too much
worry that if I was to pause for even 15
seconds that you would be you would be
thinking okay let's see what let's see
what he says after this long pause so I
don't have I don't have a worry about
that so that's first so not to be like
oh I have to say something right away so
that you know that silence is beautiful
the reason why we have music is because
there's space silence between the notes
we talk to each other their space
silence between things we say so take
your time to formulate the the best
possible thing to say so so that'd be
first is to don't be afraid of taking
that time in silence and space
the next thing is
I'm I'm a big fan of nonverbal
communication so I don't need to use
words to talk sometimes
and so just like that maybe maybe some
here's a your most simple one it's
actually really interesting to think
about why did these evolve why do we
have eyebrows right what one of the big
hypotheses about why we have eyebrows is
because of nuance and facial expressions
and communication of course there's
other things about sunlight and so that
we can actually see better absorbing
sunlight so when you say something
interesting and you finish your sentence
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
and then I didn't say anything you you
saw my eyebrows and my mouth go wow
you saw my eyebrows rise up you saw my
mouth go WOW but I didn't say anything
and I gave you that three seconds
without saying anything all of a sudden
you pick back up on your next thought so
by not saying something in that small
gap of time and by expressing
non-verbally you can let someone go on
to their next really interesting thought
whereas if you would have said something
you might have cut it off
so I'd say nonverbal communications big
you know eye contact is obviously big
another thing is just to be have a
really good balance between humility and
confidence so be confident in your
speech I'm talking with my hands and I'm
talking loudly because I'm confident in
my body posture in my gesticulation I'm
confident and my voice is loud and but
balance that with humility so if I need
to I can tune it back and I can be
quieter and I can be calmer and I can be
more warm and inviting and I can be
humble when I know that you have so much
to teach so it's kind of those things
are big ones for me on how to orally
present oneself at the best the two to
two mics hello Alan and I'm Tong an
undergraduate student studying biology
and I really appreciate your idea to
share the opinions from the greatest
minds to everyone but I wonder whether
you question too much in your daily life
because your job is to you ask questions
so I wonder what about when you are
dealing with your families
and friends how do you see a question
that big questions I think for daily
lives we have to let it go sometimes so
how do you deal with that do you balance
between your thoughts when you're at
work or and the ones when you're at home
mm-hmm interesting question okay
we've all had scenario where we're maybe
we're butting heads a little bit against
our mom or our dad or a brother or a
sister in some way we're butting heads a
little bit and we know that if we if we
double down if I push a little harder
you're most likely you're not going to
end up they're gonna say oh okay now I
understand and then they'll agree with
you most likely not it usually ends up
if you push even harder they push harder
too so sometimes it's better to ask if
you can ask a question you know why do
you think that way and then learn from
their perspective and then thank them
and then move on to the other thing and
so that's that's big because a happy
family is makes for a happy work and a
happy the rest of the life so this is
this is very important to make sure at
home everything is calm and loving and
compassionate and vibrant and and not
you know hectic and chaotic and evil and
all that stuff so so to do our best to
kind of like you know be the loving
force at home be the love the force of
love at home and then that will help all
of a sudden maybe your mom or dad or
brother or sister will become more
loving as well and you'll be like how
did that happen and that usually comes
from you and it usually comes from us
from changing our behavior and our
approach to it so yeah the the thought
was I seem to be pretty good for my
family I I had to also go through a very
long training process myself of I used
to push push push and I did I just get
hit back in my face all the time and
then I stopped pushing and I started
asking the question about it
well how why do you think that way how
do you feel about that
and then they answer and I say and then
and I just lay off and maybe you know if
someone's feeling a little bit agitated
go go out to go go for a walk go out to
nature come back you know you'll be more
calm they'll be more calm after some
time away too but I you I it took a long
time for me to get better at it and now
also the relationships get better over
time like another really important thing
about this is you know how many of you
still have both of your parents are
alive almost all of you how how many of
you are they still together in the same
house maybe you're still together in the
same house okay
so not so many so but why why I ask is
because you have you have this you have
this a mom and dad that brought you into
the world if they didn't decide they
were in in love and they wanted to have
a child and bring a child into the world
you wouldn't be here and so at least for
us when we get older when were maybe 25
30 years old we're a little older some
of us even when were only 20 20 years
old if we can do this when we're
just 20 it's even better but can you go
up to your mom and can you tell her I
love you thank you for holding me in
your stomach nine months growing me in
your stomach and bringing me into this
world can you tell her that and what
would happen if you did what would
happen to your dad if you told your dad
thank you so much for bringing me into
the show thank you for the support and
the love because when you were a child
when you were 0-1 years old two years
old did you make money and pay your own
rent no your food was there for you your
rent was there your house was there for
you all these things were there for you
it's because your parents did it so if
you can remember to go back to the
parents and to tell them thank you for
that it changes our relationship with
our parents and it makes for the family
to be a happier healthier place which
makes your work healthier happier than
the rest of your life
my name is yang gongju and majoring Cell
Metabolism
through day's talk I'm wondering some
people talking interesting and some some
people boring not the words not their
appearance not their face I'm wondering
how to turn to right turn or hers to get
right communication okay
so say the question again how to turn to
a right
tongue all hurts to get right
communication some like the right tone
and the right words for the right
communication okay okay
life sciences is familiar with mirror
neurons so if you if if I if the person
you're talking to is a little bit maybe
they're moving with their hands maybe
they have higher energy than you two
maybe a little bit hand movement little
higher energy if they maybe take a step
back and they're quieter and they're
calmer then you also quieter calmer
mirroring them helps them become more
comfortable and in terms of tone and the
right words something that comes up for
me about the right words is that an even
tone is that you know when someone
finishes one of their statements they
can kind of like they can finish their
statement with the tone that kind of
makes it seem like it's a question but
they didn't ask it like a question they
said a comment but it was like question
and they kind of may go like this at the
very end so what you're doing by doing
something like that is um you're showing
more vulnerability and you're showing
more humility and you're showing that um
you may not be right and so it helps
helped me a lot as an interviewer for me
when I venture into something that I
don't know much about right let's say
like neuromodulation and I might say you
know is it is it you know maybe that I
ask a question about up to genetics and
I ask like well could up to genetics be
helpful for eradicating Alzheimer's
and I you know I asked it like this so
I'm saying well could it be helpful er I
read that it was helpful what do you
think you know so my tone and my words
show that I'm very vulnerable and humble
and open to them teaching me versus if I
say that well I read that it was helpful
and and you know and they you know
they'll be like well you know so that
there's like there's this can you can we
carry a tone of maybe softer more gentle
with with the way that we ask and then
another thing that came up was that I've
I've over stretched myself before and I
mention that earlier too that be careful
with words sometimes it's better to use
a more simple word than to incorrectly
use a more complex word so that's been
something else that I've learned so also
one more thing take a question that
you're asking
write it down
10 optogenetics eradicate Alzheimer's
write it down again below it and change
up some of the words can optogenetics
eradicate neurodegeneration you know
nerve degeneration being more broad so
can you change the words in the sentence
if you write it you know 5 times
changing the words in it and you can
make it so that the sentence itself is
the best version of the sentence that it
could be the question this is what
authors do authors of books they go and
they take a specific sentence in the
book and they write it out 10 different
ways and they find the best way the
sentence expresses the most meaning and
they put it back into the into the book
before they publish it this is how they
work on iterations of the sentences so
think of the best possible words to use
in the in the sentence the best
structure of the sentence moto-meter in
physics and we like shared some of your
most enjoyable and self-satisfied
interviews my most enjoyable interviews
yeah yes and what would you what would
you like to know like the person I
interviewed the subject why I enjoyed it
this type of stuff Oh them all those ok
thank you for asking something that a
lot of people aren't thinking about is
how to both find people like we were
talking about this list of these hot
five hot 10 hot top 20 people how do you
have both people that are already like
they have lots of prominence they have
lots of papers they have lots of you
know big big big stuff big badges but
how do you also find the people that
don't have any of that but that are
doing very interesting work and so
that's been something for me with the
people that we've interviewed I've been
able to find people that are very under
the radar nobody really knows about them
in the big media and I like finding them
and showcasing them so like sandy and
joyous heart were two that are really
deeply passionate about spirituality and
about meditation and about ways of
self-actualization of bringing ourselves
fully into the world and I found them
featured them but then on this other
side of things there's people like you
know dr. Jordan Peterson or dr. George
Church dr. max tegmark right these other
leaders that are already in the media
they've done TED Talks they've they go
and frequently speak in front of a
thousand people you know whatever they
have tons of papers tons of companies
working on big challenges in the world
and so I like featuring them and
learning from them too and asking them
questions they've never been asked
before that's a big one because how
often do they get interviews a lot how
often do they get a question that
they've never been asked before not so
often and so if you ask them a question
that they've never been asked before
that shows them that you understand
their most important parts of their view
and also that wow I've never been asked
it that
that before then you earn a place in
their in their worldview as someone that
they remember they'll remember you and
so that's another thing is to strive for
such excellence in the world that people
remember you I like it when it feels
like the guest and myself are are
harmonizing are vibrating on a very high
level so I try and make an environment
where they can feel most alive most
coming from their heart and their mind
and their spirit soul at their best and
so I like I like that that that vibe
makes me feel most alive too and it
likely makes our audience feel most
alive so those are those are the big
ones but yeah everything from the
complete people don't know of all the
way to the people the ones that people
do know of and you'll find the
interesting people that under the common
later yeah it's a great question - yeah
something really interesting that was
discovered maybe about I think almost
five years ago now is that um you can
tell by someone's fanaticism or
basically by how endogenously motivated
they are which means like how
intrinsically motivated they are so I'm
not motivated by a car or a house or a
watch but I'm instead I'm motivated by
scientific discovery I'm motivated by
bringing myself most fully into the
world that type of stuff so the more
that there endogenously motivated the
more they do really weird things like
you'll find someone that's maybe under
there
are you'll find them like on the
internet talking about like some of the
deepest stuff in that field at like 3:00
in the morning so house how passionate
does someone have to be about the
subject if they're going to be online
talking about it at 3 in the morning
so you've it's like very there can be
some very interestingly weird ways to
find these people so when you when you
go out to do you guys do like networking
events right so when you go out to like
a networking event remember I mentioned
to you guys earlier that I rarely go out
but when I do it's to a big networking
event that I want to connect with people
at and so when you go there you can do
something like have your maybe you want
to become a co-founder of a company so
you're trying to find the partner to
co-found the company with or maybe you
want to find the person there that knows
about the specific thing that you're
looking for what you do is you look you
you forming that question if you write
it down a bunch of times and you figure
out how to best ask it you're basically
you're querying the event you're running
a query of the event and so you go and
you ask the question you asked the
question you asked the question question
question question question you ask the
question to as many people as you can
and you find the ones that give the best
response those are the ones that could
potentially be your co-founder or those
the ones that could help you with that
research that type of stuff so the more
people that you ask that question - the
more you likely you'll find - someone
that is the right candidate for either
the interview or for the founding of the
company that kind of stuff so that's
been another thing that I've that I've
done quite a bit yeah and I'm also a
little bit like like here's you know
here's me like if you give if you give
the really good answer to to the
question and I know that you would be a
good person to keep in touch with this
is what I do right away
that was so cool can we keep in touch on
on WeChat can I message you you know
right away I just go right away and they
said yeah sure and then I'm like then we
scan and then we become friends I
message you my name my email right away
my phone number so you have it you know
so we're in touch and so don't wait well
don't wait why are you waiting if
someone's really interesting get their
contact information and follow up with
them the next day that was great to meet
you
you know here's that paper I was talking
about what do you think about it do you
want to meet up on Thursday for coffee
and talk about it more I'll come with
more research because when you don't
take this out and do it right away you
forget about them they forget about you
the opportunity goes away so seize the
moment carpe diem seize the day
get the get connected right away to the
person that you find interesting and
follow up with them through food bring
new technologies each esteem allergy
feels
is that it we're done with questions
does everyone feel that's good yes yes
so the opportunities are we have lunch
happening now you guys can come lunch
talk we have every every day I'm going
to be doing interviews here so if you
want to have lunch or dinner together
just connect with me on wheat shot and
we can meet up and we can do lunch or
dinner together I know that a lot of you
are doing really cutting-edge research
too so I want to learn from you so I'd
love to ask you questions about you know
your life here in China about what
you've been studying all that kind of
stuff I find it really interesting I'll
be happy to share with you about what's
happening in Silicon Valley - in
California and in the United States just
remember that you know the things that
we talked about take action take action
that's most important otherwise we go
back to the same that we were so if we
can take at least one new habit and
begin implementing it that can make a
big difference in who you meet who you
work with what you pursue how much money
you make how successful you are all that
kind of stuff so that's a I'm so
grateful to Peking University - shrill
in to you long to all of you guys for
coming thank you sure thank you thank
you
[Applause]
hey I learned a lot from your lecture
today I think the Chinese people are
more shy and did not going to get that
in touch with that with other people
even they think their interest and may
be helpful with their future for me I
watched a lot of American movies and I
learned a lot from American culture that
day I never never feel they are lower in
a lower case war no no already I want to
say wow that I I think Americans they
have a big advantage that is they never
feel them incompetent and you know I am
trying to do that and to learn from
Toronto so I want to could I have your
beach at of course yeah you you were so
confident you came right up right away
you know what I mean from when you said
they you're like I'm shy and then you
walked on it you know what I mean
sometimes it's my thang and like if we
change the way that we think about
ourselves we can change the way that we
come into the world aren't ya it's
partly true and actually quantum
mechanics is improving I'm more in are
that that's true
you have all of the potentials in the
looking pick which one you want to I'll
talk if you stay for lunch we talk yes
okay for lunch okay cool
[Music]